why so serious because this fan favorite
performance in John Wick chapter 4 was
channeling none other than Heath Ledger
no kidding the fourth John Wick movie
has blown away the box office and earned
some of the best reviews of the entire
franchise while a lot of Praise
rightfully goes toward the lead Keanu
Reeves and director Chad stachelski the
film introduces many exciting new
characters that could easily spin off
into their own franchises including the
tracker aka Mr Nobody true to his name
Mr Nobody is a blank slate Bounty Hunter
who's only interested in taking out John
Wick if he can get as much money out of
it as possible he aligns himself with
various forces throughout the movie
along with his trusted canine putting
him in a very interesting position by
the end of the film and there are many
directions he can go because there's
still a lot the audience doesn't know
about him that's intentional an actor
Shamir Anderson looked toward another
mysterious antagonist for inspiration
Heath Ledger's Joker in The Dark Knight
as he told vulture her I looked at the
Joker and studied a lot of what Heath
Ledger did how exciting that character
was you just knew that guy had a robust
past like why did he get those scars and
for me why do I have this canine why do
I have this knapsack why am I dressed
like this the result is a thrilling new
character that should absolutely get
more time on the big screen when an
actor's trying to build a bad guy from
the ground up drawing inspiration from
one of the best movie villains of all
time is an excellent place to start
there's also much the audience doesn't
know about Heath Ledger's Joker and that
makes him all the more terrifying Shamir
Anderson took what was accessible about
his character and fleshed him out from
there going on to State this guy's
transient he has pockets because he
travels so much he doesn't really change
that notebook you see in the film I took
that home and wrote A Lot in there that
knapsack that he had on I had a lot of
personal items like dog toys dog treats
lighters engraved with my name I just
had to put my DNA on this the part about
writing in the notebook seen in the film
is an interesting pair well to Heath
Ledger's preparation to play Joker the
actor infamously kept a diary to jot
down his character's villainous thoughts
during production including lines of
dialogue he had in the film
well you look nervous
is it the scars
you want to know how I got them all of
Anderson's hard work appears to have
paid off he concluded his comments by
saying I think it's translating as
people are infatuated with the tracker
in a film like John Wick chapter 4 which
has many highlights being one of the
best parts is definitely a compliment
and a testament to Anderson's talents he
may have channeled Heath Ledger's Joker
for inspiration in John Wick chapter 4.
but Anderson is also a fan of another
actor who played a villain in the Dark
Knight franchise in that same interview
with vulture Anderson said that he'd
love to star in a Mr nobody's spin-off
with Liam Neeson who played Roz Al ghoul
in Batman Begins and The Dark Knight
Rises and he's not the only performer
Anderson would be interested in Walking
the boards with speaking of people he'd
love to go up against in movies he said
Liam Neeson would be a great antagonist
I think Denzel Washington would be a
crazy antagonist it would be really
interesting to see a female villain
Meryl Streep would be something
different so those are my top three
choices Denzel Washington Liam Neeson
and Meryl Streep it remains to be seen
if Mr nobody will ever get his own
spin-off in the meantime fans can look
forward to returning to the John Wick
Universe via the continental and
ballerina spin-offs in the near future
[Music]